aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
choisie par naïma ghermani et grâce à
son travail
on va comprendre comment un moine et son
portrait on provoque une réforme
religieuse qui a bouleversé l'europe
[Musique]
à première vue ce portrait du
réformateur allemand n'a rien de celui
d'une star c'est un simple portrait
d'une vingtaine de centimètres de haut
on est loin des impressionnants
portraits grandeur nature que charles
quint son souverain fait faire de
lui-même à la même époque dans les
années 1530
sauf qu'à l'époque à voir son portrait
c'est un signe de distinction sociale
arar un portrait peint ça coûte cher ça
nécessite de longues heures de pause et
de travail bref c'est un bien très
précieux
d'autant plus que celui-ci ait peint par
lukas kanak l'un des peintres les plus
célèbres de l'époque
mais si lutter en a un c'est parce qu en
1533 il au sommet d'une gloire qu'il n'a
pas cherché en fait avant ce portrait il
est déjà l'un des personnages les plus
représentés de son temps et de son pays
on compte aujourd'hui près de 500
portraits de lui alors comment expliquer
cette médiatisation incroyable et
inédite de lutter au xiiie siècle
l'église avait décrété que les fidèles
pouvait racheter leur faute
après avoir confessé en échange d'argent
c'est ce qu'on appelle les indulgences
le pape se réservait de plus en plus le
pouvoir d indulgence
d'abord pour les croisades puis pour
répondre aux angoisses des fidèles et à
ses besoins financiers
l'église étant des mêmes l'indulgence au
péché futur et à ceux des défunts avant
1517 le terme n'est qu'un simple moine
docteur en théologie mais indignée par
les procédés de l'église il envoie à
l'archevêque albert de mayence une
lettre accompagnée de 95 thèses où il
rappelle le salut par la foi seule et
quelques jours plus tard et peut-être
par erreur ses thèses sont affichés sur
la porte du château de wilton berg en
fait sans l'avoir prévu lutter introduit
une réforme religieuse profonde qui
divise l empire avant de diviser
l'europe les années 1530 son set de la
stabilisation de la réformation luther
apparaît désormais vêtu d'un long
manteau noir et d'un béret sombre et
l'occupent une grande partie de la
surface du tableau
à une époque où la corpulence est
associée à la puissance sociale et
politique font sobre aucun accessoire
très presque simplifiée image un peu
plate lutter incarne le modèle pastorale
légitime à suivre ses portraits ne
permettent pas seulement de partager le
visage du réformateur
il symbolise surtout un ordre nouveau ce
visage a été tant diffusé
vue et commentée qu'on leur connaît
immédiatement le portrait de lutter est
devenu non pas une icône mais un signe
un signe de ralliement pour ceux qui se
réclament de son église
merci à naïma ghermani qui nous a permis
de faire cette vidéo et à bientôt sur
une image une histoire